welcome to philanthropy in action where
we engage philanthropist activists
students and the community in
discussions on how we use our time
talent and treasure to make the world a
better place
I am maxim thorn and I teach
philanthropy in action at Yale
University
today's guest is Harry Belafonte an
American hero and philanthropist thank
you for coming Harry we also have Yale
University students as part of our
conversation and I welcome them to the
show please introduce yourselves
starting with Assad hi mr. Belafonte my
name is Osso dominat I'm a sophomore
here at Yale I'm originally from Los
Angeles California and it's really a
pleasure to have you here thank you hi
my name is Connor Bell I'm a junior from
Lynchburg Virginia I'm a history major
and I have a particular interest in
public health and global health
hi mr. Belafonte thank you so much for
being here it's such an honor to have
you here
my name is sesame adecco I was born and
raised in East Africa between Eritrea
and Ethiopia but my family now lives in
Los Angeles hi my name is Linda Lai I am
a junior history major and I'm
originally from Shanghai China hi my
name is Robert Josh Nikki I'm a freshman
from New York City I'm majoring in
computer science or math and I'm
interested in building robots building
robots yeah okay hi my name is Carl Chen
I'm a junior studying sociology and I'm
from Oak Park California which is
outside LA and I'm interested in social
movements great to see all of you thank
you
Thank You students Harry Belafonte is
1956 album Calypso made him the first
artist in history to sell more than 1
million albums he has won both a Tony
Award and an Emmy and he was awarded the
National Medal of Arts by President
Clinton he has served as a UNICEF
Goodwill Ambassador and is the recipient
of the Kennedy Center Honors for
excellence in the Performing Arts he has
recently collaborated on a memoir and
documentary film chronicling his life
he resides with his lovely wife Pamela
in New York City thanks so much for
coming it's so Harry Belafonte to my
mind put that together Harry Belafonte
to my mind one of the most inspiring
aspects of your life is the way that you
have used your time your talent and your
treasure to change the world and to make
it better in my view that makes you one
of the greatest philanthropist do you
agree with the way with that term when
we refer to you well as you described
how I've used my life there is truth to
that I didn't set out to be a
philanthropist and work at philanthropy
for me what I did and what I do is just
a part of the the more fundamental
aspects of one's humanity I think we
should all be philanthropists or in
philanthropy I think this part of the
generosity of the human spirit and the
human soul how did you come to that how
did you come to that belief by ducking
philanthropists I gated that out of out
of social experience I was born into
poverty and poverty dictated the way in
which I would meet the challenges of
life and my mother was also a victim of
poverty and I watch what she did with
mobility and with dignity and the way in
which she met the challenges hugely
influenced my take on what I should be
doing with my life when I came of age I
was able to make my own decisions and
court and chart my own course if there
was must have been tough decisions at
the time in which you came of age which
was some turbulent times how did you get
involved for example with market of the
King
and the civil rights movement I mean you
had a career you were you were launching
yourself as one of the biggest stars if
not the biggest star in music and and
and on the screen but this must have
been challenging for you all of it is
challenging but when I first became
aware of a good fortune that was being
put for me the great question for me is
what do I do with with this power what
do I do with this inflow of influence
and the resources and the capacity to
have people at least pause long enough
to hear what you have to say and it
became quite evident based upon role
models and other social experiences that
to serve the cause of justice which was
my main goal the biggest thing about
poverty for me was the injustice of it a
crushing human humiliating aspects of
daily life begging your way through each
each encounter and that seemed to me to
be quite any inhumane my mother's
construction to me was
never go to bed at night knowing that
there was something I could have done to
fight injustice and never engaged myself
and that in that confrontation so from
early on I understood the way of I saw
injustice my commitment and my task was
to resist it to challenge it and to
change it no matter how minimal the
event might appear to be or how large it
might in the how Lord would reveal
itself and that became a practice became
a pattern became a habit so when I made
a lot of money
outside of the immediate needs to
extricate myself from debt and to put my
family into some place of a more
balanced social experience the rest was
about how do you change the universe and
how do you use your resources your
talent the money the influence
personality or DNA how do you put it all
into the pot and get on with trying to
make the world a better place than the
way in which you found it
and that was just my life I didn't
challenge it I was challenged but each
time I step to the plate and people
asked for my services or indicated and
interest in my services I easily gave it
because I became committed to their
cause to the cause y'all should have
been and are still committed to
philanthropy to me is uh there's a class
distinction it has a an aura that means
it is something that the wealthy do and
most of the time when you look at the
way in which philanthropy is
administered I often look at it as
somebody buying their right to a greater
humanity than they in fact lived and
somehow philanthropy was the way in
which those who crushed humanity failed
of that fact by just giving to those
whom they crushed giving to those whom
they abused and for me the idea
philanthropy always carried with it a
great suspicion as to what motivates
this philanthropy once you get past that
initial of question I then began to
understand the importance having to
encourage philanthropy to invest itself
and the issues of justice
so that became more productive for me to
seduce philanthropy to the causes that I
felt committed to change then just to
ignore philanthropy it cheated as a
class issue and move on elsewhere it
made no sense and in that context I
began to develop friendships and
relationships system fairly powerful
people and institutions and showed a
great deal of philanthropy or responded
with a great deal of philanthropy and a
lot of them we wouldn't have achieved
many of the things we did had it not
been for their intervention so despite
the ambivalence
despite the conflicts beside trying to
wrestle with the definition I soon got
over that because there are a lot of
complicated things to the system of life
that we have found ourselves at both
economically and politically and life is
a constant sorting out of how to make
this thing work thank you
let's go to our students as add yes so
when Julianne professor Julian Bond
visited us at Yale we had a we had him
come speak to the class and he he
mentioned you and your kind of gravitas
as a leader and kind of icon during the
civil rights movement and he told one
anecdote that was especially moving
about how during a march that he was
present at the normal type of hate and
and cussing and people throwing things
was was there and was present and midway
through the March you kind of showed and
where they were there and people started
to recognize and kind of slowed down and
and kind of halted there there kind of
attack on the on the March and you know
there was this kind of oh that's how
Harry Belafonte here and I was kind of
wondering how do you deal with this sort
of admiration for your image
while at the same time kind of facing
this this idea of race and this kind of
hate that that was clearly present there
before but you know is kind of removed
with your with your celebrity status or
kind of position
of fame while celebrity is a terrible
virus exists at so many levels and in so
many ways and the great question about
celebrity is it's it's it's obvious
power and most people who are touched by
celebrity having one or two choices to
self anoint to use that celebrity in the
service of the acquisition of more
celebrity or to use that celebrity and
use that spotlight of celebrity and turn
it to focus on something that you think
will enhance the needs of the human
family I find that that kind of service
is far more rewarding and just the
acquisition of more material power or
more wealth or more celebrity I find
that having been given that kind of
recognition on that platform I was aware
that as an artist I had a capacity to
say and to do things that cause people
to linger just a bit longer on any
question that might be before them if a
celebrity were handling the manipulation
of how to approach that question I had a
hands on that question and then when I
found that there was that space
I found an opportunity to make a lot of
noise and to say a lot of things and to
lead people to places that might change
the way in which I found them and how do
you how do you interact with with those
who you you clearly see as you know
having a sense of a different sense of
race or in some case a racist mentality
but treating you with a different sort
of respect even though you come from a
different background er how do you how
do you engage those who have this kind
of mental blockade in terms of race and
and kind of allow your celebrity to work
through
through that that that sense of hate the
racist characteristic but evidences
itself in America touches everyone we
can measure response by the extent of
how this racist view is applied or acted
upon some people can become very they
cruel very brutal they can take human
life I rooted in the extent of their
passions on the a racist belief some
other people just move through life in a
very casual way accepting that there
exists this difference in that
difference will never be bridged they've
already shut the door so when you come
up against racism you have to not first
of all understand the level on which it
exists how is it being applied and then
you can begin to dismantle it based upon
the tools you need to help in the
process so that if I meet you and I
suspect that you have some racist
thoughts lingering the first thing I
approach you with is a smile and in that
fact if there is such a friendly
overture a lot will be said about how we
get on from the men and how you handle
that smile I learned a lot of this from
my dealings with dr. King of a positive
encounter the or can always meet persons
and necessarily because so much of life
is filled with adversarial experience or
you can meet people in a position of
have a serial clash or encounter and
choose to take the sting out of that
adversarial behavior how do you disarm
the enemy how do you change the paradigm
how do you shift the mood how do you
take all of this to another playing
field and from that point of view the
the chessboard of life is hugely
fascinating to me because I will look
something
and see that we have lost ground or have
come upon a cruel moment and while I may
be been born the loss and them only are
the results of such a tragedy my first
inclination is then how do I fix it how
do I beat it I'm coming back to this
course it needs to be dealt with and
then comes that challenge and then comes
the chance to exercise imagination
exercise environmental gifts to bring
things to bear to just make a difference
and I find making it different every
level of the human encounter is an
important way in which to apply your
tools and your gifts and I can casually
pass you by and leave you undisturbed
without with anything oh I can pass you
by and engage you and inform you it's
something you may never have known
before that might change the way would
you see me or see the life you live I
think it's how we treat the gift of life
if you've given all these things of the
world to work all your senses are alive
your imagination the capacity to
exercise free thinking to challenge what
what those who would oppress you would
have you believed to be the truth are
the only truth of the dogma all these
things are constantly out there and what
a wonderful encounter to be able to just
challenge these things yourself and find
new solutions in new ways I cannot
tolerate conformity it defies me
something should be embraced but if I
conform to a negative set of principles
then I'm encouraging that negativity and
enhancing that oppression my thing is
wherever I see it I challenge you know
that reminds me of a famous quote George
George Bernard Shaw since that fitting
in is death but the other quote is
sitting in a what fitting in is death
George Bernard Shaw absolutely one of
the things that I love about your
approach to life and why you personally
but also your work inspires me is this
enthusiasm that you show and the humor
that you bring to these experiences and
some of these are really tough
experiences and just to drop in another
quote you know Winston Churchill has a
saying that I've also embraced in which
he says and also because I've made so
many mistakes in my own life that
success is going from failure to failure
but with enthusiasm and that enthusiasm
must be part of your makeup because in
some of the stories about reaching out
to people to get them to invest in snick
and to get raise money to bail students
out or other young kids out of jail who
are being arrested must have taken its
toll on you and yet and yet you brought
with it such a compassion such such a
humor it is that was that's is that part
of your strategy or just part of your
DNA both let me give you a quick a quick
example of an experience that for town
maybe tell you oh how I am required to
greet life during the civil rights
movement well there we are at the some
of the most critical moments in our
confrontation with the system it was
extremely important that we win the
justice system of our country our
government we win it to our cause
because the thing that most oppressed us
or the laws that existed the segregation
laws the laws the racial oppression the
laws of denial the laws that said I
couldn't go
school of that school and this constant
machine of oppression and an alienation
required that we applied the most
powerful weapon we had which were the
tenants and the laws of the Constitution
what did the law say what did the
supreme law say and although many states
practice segregation the supreme law the
federal law Constitution had other
interpretations so it was important to
us to win those who were the
administrators of law administrators of
justice those who manipulate it the
language of judgment and when John
Kennedy was president
we waited with with great anticipation
for who would he appoint at the head of
the Justice Department the most
important agency in government for us
and he appointed his brother Bobby
Kennedy and what little we knew of Bobby
Kennedy suggested to us that was not
going to be a joyous ride very rich very
Irish very from from a foreign
environment that had no real evidence of
our relationship to people of color or
people who were poor he wasn't a bad
fellow he was just an indifferent fellow
and he wallowed and played in the play
in the lives and the indulgences of the
rich and we were poor and we were
alienated and we were being denied
access to justice and we needed to have
his opinion fall in favor with the
things we were trying to achieve and
when we discussed the fact that that'd
be an impossible task because when he
came to the to the role of Attorney
General he had already been a legal
voice for the house on American
Activities Committee which is a very
cruel agency that did a lot of witch
hunting and branded people unpatriotic
and Victor of villains of
our pure order as a society and/or call
communists and things that were
considered to be unfavorable titles and
he was part of that machine he was part
of that that that process and when he
became Attorney General that's how we
saw him so the point of this story is
that giving you that background is that
dr. King in listening to our evaluations
and assessment of him said to us I've
heard anything you had to say and very
little as challengeable except that he
is the Attorney General and we need him
and your task is to go find his moral
center and went into our cause so the
mission was more than just how do you
end if you laid him as the administrator
of justice and how he would interpret it
you had to study the van and know more
about his humanity and his taste and his
social habits and win him through a
social encounter that took us off the
dime and kept having us relate to one
another based upon our social
experiences but the truth of the matter
is that for those of you who look at the
arc of that history at the end of his
life I don't think there was a voice
that was possessed of more moral power
and more moral clarity than Bobby
Kennedy had he lived and had he become
the president the United States the 21st
century would be an infinitely different
canvas than the one we're experiencing
so winning him winning his humanity
helping to cleanse the process for him
and for us to be able to make an
exchange
put us into a relationship of mutual joy
and mutuality was extremely important
the law and the rest of it became
another objective but we did both and I
think in that context a nation was
enhanced considerably by the fact that
Bobby Kennedy and Alton and his brother
too in a way
although I often say that history
created
John Kennedy more than John Kennedy
created history the system and those are
so activist pushed the Kennedy
administration to do things they would
not ordinarily have done the youth in
particular and the anti-war movement and
Vietnam and women's rights and a lot of
hosts of racial and social issues we're
just brought to the to the to the
surface of human experience were in the
streets were whatever way you went you
came up against this force for change
and the administration had to deal with
us the politics of their own interests
were at stake
and we knew this and we played all these
themes as cleverly as we could as
righteously as we could in but there's
much more aloof as we could summon and
in the end we prevailed I have to say
young people a lot of times you know we
never lost a battle in the civil rights
movement we never we didn't win the war
the war is still going on and it's a
huge war but we never lost a battle
anything we've set out to do to change
laws to change social perception to
change the way in which women were
treated in the south us as a activists
in their own communities are being
lawyers of it you couldn't get a white
or black woman in the south to be a
lawyer because the courts had gender in
positions that denied them the right to
practice law fully so in that sense what
we did changed the way in which America
was thinking albeit we didn't get to the
rest of it with as much enthusiasm and
passion as we should have so now we're
trying to pick those pieces up and today
is void and see if we can carry on with
what we originally set out to to sorry
for bezel own lengthy in the end
Karl so you're saying we never lost the
battle but we're still fighting this war
do you and I just came from a class
taught by Bob Herbert and he was saying
how he was painting this very bleak
picture of America kind of and
essentially saying what we need now to
kind of fix America isn't incremental
reforms or maybe or not not just
incremental reforms and not just maybe a
social entrepreneurship but a full-out
social movement like we had in the 60s
with the civil rights movement or with
the women's movement or the labor
movement what do you what do you think
about that do you think that's what
that's what's needed right now do you
think that's possible to be created
again I don't even think we have a
choice it's what will be regardless of
what you think regardless of what I may
think of feel they're their
inevitabilities on the way they will
just roll over you because that's the
way history treats it this problem has
been in part of civil cycle forever I
mean when you talk about capitalism and
you're talking about free capital and
the flow of money and trade and
internationalism and all that kind of
stuff a certain group rose up that we
now see as the capitalist class for the
rich people and they dominated the
economics of our of our societies well
one of the earliest glues to the success
of that economic process was the
exploitation of human beings and the
first major exploitation here in America
of human human property of human energy
was what we did to the Native Americans
Europeans came they conquered and they
needed cheap labor and a workforce and
he conscripted the Indians to fall in
and on the slave traditions forced them
into extinction as a people because they
just so cruelly treated them as cheap
labor as as commodity and not with a
humanity and when they ran out of that
group and they were extinguished or at
least
removed in a great totality oh they went
out and imported the next group of wage
earners and and the workers and that was
slavery and that a century of that with
black people cheap no value no human
value no worth morally deficient and
when that system played itself out as
much as I couldn't that to be changed it
an instituted its next set of rules
which are was segregation and they had
divide and conquer and keep people still
in that chief labor into that useless
place of life because the rich
determined who you were what you were to
be called and how you endured now jumped
today what fascinates me is that in the
20th century and certainly in the
dawning of the 21st century we saw huge
appeals we saw the Soviet Union and the
Communist Russia implode now everybody
thought that if that dynasty of that
power was at all be eradicated it would
be in the midst of bloodshed and tyranny
and great tragic forces clashing and
nuclear war but it came and went without
a shot being fired
so buddy you can say well that's a
coincidence to history but then you say
okay let's change the environment let's
change the scenario let's go to a place
where the issue was race not economic
oppression but race and here in South
Africa
you had the largest population of
Africans
black Africans being exploited by
European minority very cruelly with
apartheid everybody expected when
Africans got free they would just
destroy white people in an act of
vengeance but the truth of the matter is
the society transformed and not a shot
was fired and people began to find ways
in which to integrate and come together
because the those systems no longer work
they imploded they died out of their own
cholesterol then you look at so many
other things and what fascinates me
about America is we sit with some sense
of arrogance with the fact there they go
there go those empires there go of those
extreme forces and we're the only ones
left and what's happening we are
imploding we are in a crisis that is
unique to all other crisises at least in
our time the the economic collapse
you're looking at is because the system
just doesn't work and now it has nobody
to blame it's running on its own on its
own on its own juice and the more it
does the more it fails and whether it's
what's going on at Wall Street and
whether it's the way which they have run
off with the Treasury and whether
they're making laws and rules that
further oppress you see I think that
system in a dying stage in a dying phase
and what's coming in is that force which
will replace whatever that system will
be replaced with and hopefully give me
the sanity that comes from an active
citizenry people who are a great center
for common humanity and will help turn
Occupy Wall Street or Occupy New Haven
or Occupy whatever because that's what
it is
now people can have a rather you know
interesting intercourse with
intellectual debate and try to find
reason and rhyme and and then and and
contain these things in ways that are
not applicable but the fact is that
these things happen when the civil
rights movement came into being we were
considered dirty people
mindless wasteful Pryor's people who
suck off the state do all those things
and yet we changes the nation and we
changed the value system of a country
not successfully enough completely but
successfully and these were the battles
that were being fought the war is still
there we were coming back now with a new
a new energy and that puts all out of
this squarely on your plate because you
mentioned Julian Bond before he was
younger than you when we met and in the
movement
Julian was 20 John Lewis was 18 Diane
Nash will let a lot of snake in the
movement was 17 and a half years old
with child and I know all on campuses
around American studying - all the
things they were doing but they
abandoned that part of their social
experience and engaged in the issues of
social change and they did a hell of a
job and I would say now the balls on in
your court
your turn what do you got for me
no no that that's exactly what I wanted
to hear I think now the client of
question is I was I was reading I think
an interview you did with the route on
if you gave some opinions on Occupy Wall
Street and I was thinking now and
especially just listening to Bob Herbert
he was saying how all these movements
accomplished a lot but they ultimately
flamed out and in and wanting to start
maybe a more sustainable movement how
what do you think is like the first
thing or what are some of the things
that we should really focus on I think
if you really look at the way in which
justice is administered you'd find that
the first thing was really in need of
repair everybody needs a job we should
have work and you know fair wages and
fair employment and all that stuff but
there's an underlying essence that's a
hardly ever discussed and it's justice
because it is how justice reveals itself
in the midst of these efforts that
ultimately tells you what kind of course
were you on it is mind-boggling to me
that they should have met in men
with great power who stole the National
Treasury then the tune of trillions of
dollars that cannot be found that cannot
be reclaimed and when it came time to
look at justice and how to stop this and
sanity those who repaired the moment
left the very same people who did all
this mischief in the same seats of power
and decision making without any any
discussion or debate and an answers to
the to the nation how is it possible
that we could still be sitting here
having decisions made at this very
moment by the very same people who stole
the Treasury just yesterday and were the
same thugs the same villains the same
corrupt forces how do they how do they
prevail and what is it in the public
discourse and the in the protection of
public policy that makes us all
capitulate to that to let us accept it
where's the protest where's the
resistance who is that a hold on you
guys can't go any further let's let's
discuss this problem because they're
preparing for your next demise they
haven't changed at all
what they're looking at is what they
think what the mistakes they made and
now they're fixing it so those mistakes
will not be repeated they'll create new
ones and how do they do that you've got
a Supreme Court that's locked against
justice it's of Court that's luck to an
ideology and that ideology is undermined
justice all the way so if you change the
checks and balances that were created by
the founding fathers in order to keep
the Machine of government active and and
creative and thinking and protecting the
populace then once that that's dissolved
you get the Congress now the Republicans
control the house they're on their way
to try to control the Senate those two
which were watchdogs for each other now
become one ideology they wrap up with
the executive branch because the the
President of the United States has not
used his bully pulpit
to move justice along he's been
politically fanciful you know he has
manipulated the system from a political
but the villainy still prevails how do
you challenge that how do you make it
not so and I think all these things are
being ignored or people are being
distracted but if you don't look at what
happens to justice if you look at
Homeland Security the law that is the
law of the land any one of us sitting in
this room could leave this room or not
even leave the room to a guy that can
walk in here in it command any one of
you overwhelm you take you out to a car
whisk you away and the world will never
hear from you again by the approval of
law you don't get charged because they
don't have to charge you with a crime
don't have to tell you what you did you
have no right to a lawyer you have no
right to one phone call absolutely
nothing and the law says we can do that
and that law was passed and when Barack
Obama became the prelate of the United
States he inherited that law and in his
campaign he denounced that law so my
problem with him doesn't know whether he
gave it back seven hundred billion
dollars or not my problem with him is
where is your moral Center where is your
line how can you look at this this
injustice
that prevails as part of the law of the
land with your powers the presidency to
change and you don't need the Congress
to change it ultimately you do but
certainly in these early stages you
could with the stroke of executive order
on the pen change some of this challenge
some of it awakened the public to the
fact that these law but he doesn't do
that so we sit in this moral vacuum we
sit in a place where nobody leads us to
the higher order or to the greater truth
so we sit here dealing with all these
things in these sub issues in these
subterranean ways we're busy watching
what's in the mouse trap well somebody
else is running off of the entire wedge
of trees
hurry I want to take you back to a a
startling moment in the history of civil
rights and is a moment that you helped
create I was looking at the internet
looking on the internet and there is a
clip of an interview of which you are a
part and it talks about the leaders
people who led various parts or various
contingence to the march on Washington
and in that clip there is you Harry
Belafonte there is Sidney Poitier James
Baldwin Charlton Heston Marlon Brando
Mankowitz and the interviewer and it's
an incredible ly diverse group of people
that that you were very instrumental in
putting together as a bridge builder and
and because they're not necessarily the
people you would think would come
together in the way that you brought
them together and this is important to
me personally because there was a
similar but obviously not identical
march on Washington the Julian Bond and
I participated in and this was soma no
no no I was I'm too young to be in Selma
the marriage equality March in 2008 the
race card all black people look young
but this was the marriage equality of
March in 2009 okay
and what was fascinating about this is
that part of the challenge was how do
you build a bridge between the
african-american community and gay
rights which has been a wedge issue in
fact recently we hear of people actually
conspiring to create wedges between
blacks and gays and so forth and one of
the things I think we were able to
achieve and make history is that we got
the chairman of the n-double a-c-p
Julian Bond and I introduced Julian Bond
at this march on Washington to be the
keynote speaker of the LGBT rights march
on Washington that was a powerful moment
but it's something that you did you know
40 years before that how did you achieve
that collaboration and that bridge
building and what can we learn from that
today well I I think what has to look at
the at the sector that you're talking
about all those people that you
mentioned the high profile artists they
had real dead more than commanded
respect and their space in their
triumphs or the use of their gifts as
artists and I firmly believe it is my
belief then and now that artists are
really the gatekeepers of truth our
mission and our purpose as existing
entities is to use the gift of art to
paint a picture for our universe or for
our all the members of our universe to
be inspired to see themselves in the
higher in the higher realm in a higher
order and that artists do that we we
inscribe history we did all the drawings
on the cave walls we wrote all the
currents and the Bible's and
and the ancient are says we were the
ones that told all those letters into
stone we were the ones that created the
songs and and all the imagery and art
was always been the carrier of the
history of human evolution and we have a
capacity to in revealing the truths of
life and to move people to an
inspiration inspire place to be see life
in terms of larger than we experience
has been the one entity that all empires
feel the need to conquer you look at the
church but almost everything that is
influenced all about the church and all
the churches is the way in which the
temples have been made and ordained the
way they the colored glass windows tell
you stories and the way in which Mozart
wrote all the great symphonies and the
great masses and what you listen to when
you walk into these temples you'll be
overwhelmed with the art that validates
that point of view that philosophy when
I looked at these young men because my
my charge to me was to organize my
community to organize the cultural
forces and I had to appeal to those
artists who understood that they were
the gatekeepers of truth and at their
power if they chose to use their lights
collectively could be a huge beacon and
looking for how to change America and it
worked because when I called all these
people you just mentioned and others
their presence alone forced people to
stop and to listen and to think because
we've already invaded their inner place
they're already in their psyche they're
already in their living rooms they're in
their kitchens
we're in their bedrooms they're
listening to our songs they made love to
our songs they march to our songs they
love to come to our movies and
but how we did what we did her huge
force already out there and now this
collective force comes and says let's
pause for a moment and look at the
deeper truth of our society and they
carried a huge payload into having their
presence there I'll never forget and
they all mingled up with people on the
mall citizens just absolutely were
aghast aghast but but overwhelmed with
the fact that Marlon Brando is walking
with Beulah
from Mendenhall Mississippian and
they're laugh and breaking bread
together it was an untouchable moment
and yet all these things all of a sudden
affected the way people are thinking and
looking and listening and I think the
use of celebrity in that sense was what
you saw in the film and the use of that
celebrity was constantly applied whether
or Selma to Montgomery we did it anyway
you know what happened he filled of the
courtrooms of America with our presence
influencing juries and judges with our
without a stew that steamed to say here
is what we think and a lot of times
things landed in our favor but it's how
you there's also an abuse of that
celebrity and a lot of guys who are very
visible very very successful who really
in the final analysis have not left very
much that's worthwhile in the wake of
their in Norton and success and power
they don't make any pictures that help
the human heart sing or dance they don't
help us see each other and in more
profound ways they don't help us get a
deeper insight into what we should be
doing as people as a matter of fact most
of what they do is quite destructive
because there's always pictures of
violence and suspicion and
and it's always it's always evil
overcoming justice and the guy who was
always been the hero is always smitten
with a lot of evil in this character but
it's also the way it was the system is
co-opted culture and its use culture to
service it because the dilemma that the
nation faces in this culture in this in
this economic collapse and this social
collapse it's very evident in the arts
because we are also in a cultural
collapse you're the lowest ebb of
American cultural power the way our
songs are the way our voices are the
books that are written the things the
way which we've engaged culture is
really at an all-time low and I think if
that changes a lot will be changed and
the social rhythm our social vision one
another it's an amazing thing to have at
our disposal Connor
thank you so I hope that my question
paybacks a little bit off of carl's in
studying the history of the civil rights
movement one of the things that I think
often gets talked about is the window of
opportunity that came up during the 60s
for change and some of the things that
is often talked about to go into that
are the relationships built between
people living in poverty and a direct
line to the federal government through
New Deal policies Great Society policies
the so-called war on poverty and I was
wondering based on the conversation that
we just had whether you believe that
this direct line still exists today if
it's still there or narrowing and
closing I don't think that that direct
line still exists
the the path to its resurrection and to
get that back on course I think is
critical to the choices that will be
made not only in this election but now
we manipulate governance in the
immediate future I think you know
government is as abstract as we try to
make it it's really quite tangible it's
made up of men and women who come from
the communities that we know and what
this what what this apparatus does this
mechanism does is that it's misil Ekta
process we move groups of people towards
protecting certain interests which more
often than not rely on self interests
and if a particular power within the
social norms gravitate towards one
another and ceases that power then they
cease the process so right now for
instance most of the banks and most of
the Wall Street most of the things that
the court did and since saying no
transparency and give endless money the
causes will make a huge shift in the way
in which there is a true democratic
representation for what we will hear
that will have a continued impact on the
Faculty of drawing away all the tools of
support or the humanities all the things
that we thrived on as a nation to ensure
that citizens who were in need would
never be in dire need that would always
be there and to be generous and to be
giving everything that attracted the
world at large to want to become to
America is in jeopardy
I think people always saw America's fair
people always saw America's the place
there was campaigning in behalf of
justice on behalf of good and now that
has been seriously blurred and in that
blurring
but it has dozens taken away the
humanity from the nation and the
humanity is expressed from a legislative
perspective and how do we take care of
health how do we take care how our
children are being informed what price
can you put on that there should be no
price on education as a matter of fact
it should be a human right a civil right
a social right and that everybody has
the right to education was never a
concern about how they will pay for it
and the same thing about health
if you surrendered everything else
understand we have the right to free
speech the right to health and the right
to education almost everything else will
take care of itself and these things
always come out of what is dismissed by
others as a kind of social philanthropy
which is not to the best interests of
the nation because it creates beggars it
creates it dampens enthusiasm it dampens
creativity well some of the greatest
experiences Americans and I had was at
the height of its social generosity so
you take a look just from the point of
view of culture so you take a look at
the 1920s of the 30s when the WPA was in
and they gave money to the local
communities to have art classes and
dance classes and and literature and
studied this tremendous reward and
harvest of culture from actors and
playwrights and books and Faulkner and
Hemingway and Steinbeck and and all the
great forces that I wrote to social
truths you know inspire the nation and
the best that was in us and somebody
came along one day and says enough of
that we should stop feeding that crowd
we should now exploit this harvest and
when the Capitol moved in and commanded
the cultural turf because they did art
is not controlled by artists it's
controlled by those who who put a price
on commodity because we are a commodity
they if you don't get the sponsor to
approve of you to be in a TV show that
he's
we've made and created in the images
that he wants then we're back into a
period where we don't have objectivity
we don't have multiple voices saying
things we have no contradictions and I
think when we stamped out subsidy to the
humanity humanities you stamped out a
big part of the American Heart the
American soul because uh turning around
to pull our neighbor up I've always been
the image of who we are the thing that
made slavery work at least be dismantle
in the final analysis we're not not just
the fact that black Africans seized
their moment and courageously went into
overthrowing slavery but there was a
huge amount of abolitionists and people
who had another humanity that came with
enormous philanthropy and giving and a
basket of goodies to have changed and
that change gave us a hiring society a
higher order in which to exist but the
enemy never ever sleeps never the minute
we catch a moment and change the game
they move instantly to find the counter
change and they eventually win where we
are right now in our own space in this
country those guys on the opposition
side had a 40-year plan
they weren't just looking at the
election for the next two years the next
moment and the dog catcher
they're busy saying how do we take this
whole thing off and it takes time and
patience and resources and cunning so
that in time we lost the court in time
we lost the Congress in time we lose the
executive chair and and all it should
represent or that they need is time to
have their while the rest of us down
here groveling with these
insane little ideas in these little
these little might mean minuscule things
that are not really about the real game
we're not it how can we be in a war that
has lasted longer than any encounter
this nation has ever had in an act of
hostility and nobody pays attention
nobody cares nobody gets the latest
statistic out of out of Afghanistan or
what's going and we don't really care as
a matter of fact if you could just hurry
up and get out of there
most Americans wouldn't care if that
part of the world went to hell in a
basket we haven't lost all sorts of
moral balance all sorts of analyses that
are important to the human uplifting in
existence and I make that claim to us
because that's what we said we were we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
well that's not very abstract is it it's
very specific how are you gonna fix the
gender use of just men but further in
truth that's what America is about
that's what it pumped into all of us
that's what they made us who we are I
hope gives us the diversity that sits
right here at this moment on this campus
trying to push ourselves through this
this labyrinth of stuff being thrown at
us and trying to find the answers and
the first thing I think we have to find
is where is our humanity not where's
your next job that was your next
paycheck that where is your next
occupation as important as that is it's
something far more fundamental where's
your soul what really is your where's
your moral Center what do you really
hold to be self-evident what is your
truth get that in place everything else
who work
sesson well I want to thank you again
for being here meeting with us and my
question is about the documentary senior
song I believe your daughter Gina
Belafonte was very much involved in
creating this documentary and in an
interview during the Sundance Film
Festival she said it was very important
to her that she preserved your legacy
and the legacy of those who worked so
closely with you during the civil rights
movement and I was just wondering if you
felt a sense of responsibility to share
with the world the stories of your peers
and their contributions to the black
movement and other humanitarian causes I
guess it was a responsibility but I
never saw it as a responsibility I
really didn't still don't that's sort of
the way of life I don't stuff no way how
to do it any other way
nobody has ever had as much fun with a
career than I've had I really mean that
and I woke up one day and I've sang a
little song that came from a little
village in the mountains Jamaican day I
woke up one day in the whole world there
singing that song and I walked answered
my god everybody's singing my song now
what do I do not what do I say what do I
do with this audience looks upon me so
favorably and all I could think about
was how to lead them to the things of
gave me joy the joy a diversity in the
door the joy of each other and I'm not
you know I'm not religious so let's not
make any great statements about my
spirituality you know it my spirituality
exists but I service that in a whole
other way than than what the norm would
have you think and I just think that it
was the responsibility it was a way of
life and the fact that the other seaters
I mean if you're responsible for
something it means you had to make up an
effort to go out and do it but it's no
effort for me I didn't lose anything as
much that I gained so much it's almost
vulgar
I once said to a friend of mine in
Beverly Hills at a big house like I
and looked at me and said oh man you
gave up so much you sacrifice so much
for us bro I mean you really did you
just step to the plate and look what
happened I look around the room for who
knows he could have been talking to
because you what happened what happened
well man you know Korea took a hit you
didn't this you didn't I said not Korean
took a hit you wake up every morning
talk to your agent and you're always on
the same subject how well did you do at
the box office I wake up every morning I
talked to Nelson Mandela shafted here
who got something to hang on to who got
a reward that's odd not equatable I mean
and I didn't go look for mr. Mandela I
did write him when he was in prison I
felt that was the thing I needed to do
and to get him out of prison became just
part of what my daily menu was for
dealing with injustice later on the
thing happened I never expect I never
thought he'd come out of prison I never
thought I'd see him but then I was
rewarded with that moment I looked at it
as a way to spend your life hugging
hugging Madiba and he's out here making
noise and make another day wow what a
way to go and somebody saying I I weep
for you okay you got somebody not seeing
this and in the proper context
somebody's not seeing this in the way it
should be perceived I'm having I'm out
of thought I'll having fun watch the
enemy retreat bloodlessly you mentioned
so much about your talent about singing
about being able to use your talent to
give to people joy and a part of that
talent is you know being able to put
things that are in reality into the
realm of imagination and you've done
that in philanthropy as well to be able
to lead a civil rights movement you need
pure imagination to be able to imagine a
world
without this injustice and you've
mentioned a lot about domestic issues I
was wondering what is the world that you
imagine for global citizens for people
even in the United States to be able to
look beyond their borders and to help
the people in the international sphere I
think the greatest opportunity that's
been put through bottom civilization was
yet another attempt to arrive at a forum
where there could be the Council of all
nations for people to sit and to have
the most important thing we've
experienced as a species and that is the
right to sit in a forum and to convince
each other of each other's beauty of
each other's choices and to compete in
that sense we used to do with
territorially walk and Club somebody
over the head take their village take
their tariff take their women take their
everything and in that might and power
we saw the growth of civilization it's
really something else and the United
Nations for me always said wow here's
another chance with modern technology
and and how quickly we can communicate
this forum is where we should be having
our greatest Renaissance I mean our
greatest time and the forum still exists
in its physical design the enemy and
money and powers constantly made it the
tool of least choice they're always
saying or the United Nations isn't about
anything it's just self serving what
does that mean it sort it serves herself
but they're all in the United Nations
they serve self and to serve interest is
the hot iron out whose interests harms
who and whose joy is celebrated by who
it's a place in which you don't just buy
and sell each other it's not it's not a
trade it's not a trade fair you're not
going to just negotiate the new price of
wheat the human soul human beings
and we have yet to let that humanity
emerge the way in which it should but I
think it's survived after now because
that humanity is tenaciously knocking at
the human door to say let us in let us
become part of your your daily debate
that's become part of your analysis and
I think if I am to make a reach here
that the next paradigm the next real joy
on the horizon is where women will take
this I think I think there is a thing
going on here that says all this now
lands at the doorstep of the choices
that women will make because I think men
have run out of the options for their
evil and the only thing that can help us
is the generosity of the spirit of women
coming at the table talking about life
and healing and and all the things we
dismiss them for because you have a
weaker sex and all those little things
we throw around you know it's true pity
of it but I think it's just something we
just have to make part of our popular
vocabulary and you know big deal it
isn't something there's no one thing
that's gonna come I don't think I'm
gonna be some miraculous revelation from
the heavens and a voice will come forth
and pronounce us all whatever we think
we need to be it's gonna come from and
like daily encounter and then bumping
into one another creating and growing
and building and being able to make the
selection to you what that which should
survive of course it's good and that
which should be left to nurture the rest
of life because it's going to decay
don't make any sense to you thank you
okay
Robert I just wanted to thank you again
for joining us today mr. Belafonte and I
wanted to take the discussion in a
slightly different direction in our
class discussions we've talked a lot
about how social entrepreneurs often
choose to invest in individuals more so
than they even invest in causes we've
also talked about how sometimes
opportunities arise that we instantly
know we want to support and like in a
New York Times interview you said that
you're driven largely by a sense of
rebellion even anger sometimes and with
the causes you choose but you've also
had the opportunity to work with amazing
influential individuals who've supported
where do you think you find the balance
between supporting individuals and
causes I have a propensity for
supporting individuals who embrace my
causes rather narrow rather self-serving
but one of the miracles of my journey
isn't fine look at all the people that
have really shaped history every one of
them but are in my life this experience
called me and invited me to come into
their space to become engaged in what
they did Eleanor Roosevelt to me is the
greatest woman ever in my time in my
lifetime what she was and what she did
and the way in which she did it
but in in these invitations that were
extended I walked in and I was curious
as to what specifically did they want me
to do and most of the time what they
asked me for was to use the power of my
heart to serve as some specific need
Eleanor Roosevelt had a lot of interest
in humanity and they and they the
welfare of children the human rights
manifest a manifesto that she helped
design and create led us to the
Declaration of the human rights of a
child
it was her influence that created these
documents which incidentally the human
rights of the child as the own America
is the only nation in the world
it was never signed that treaty every
other nation has come to the table
inside America refuses it says a lot
about the decay of our own sense of
mission but in every instance it was
what was after me
I never had to impose anything and they
unlocked my sense of creativity
what can I best do to make this thing
happen
and to service this cause which I have
never thought about before or never
thought I would engage so it was this
reciprocity they called I answered and
they forced me to examine in my my
toolkit what tools would I best used to
apply to the ends they wanted us to
achieve and always the thing that
nourished that was that I always trusted
them I trusted their vision I trusted
their view I trusted their humor I
trusted their humanity and therefore I
could throw myself in without any
concern for consequence it was even if
we were to die one of the great glories
and death and all other stuff was really
the fact that the Co I'm dying with you
know like if I got to close my eyes and
the last thing I see is not the king or
you you know then what a way to go it's
just everything about it said to me I'm
in the best place I can be and
everything that I did service that fact
I'm amazed at the ativ at the age of 85
in America with all of our value systems
how many but to sit here at Yale
University and talked a bunch of young
people that I never ever saw before and
may never see again but that they're
interested in my opinion is to me I
can't put a value on that
that's just touching and is meaningful
me about how my life has been spent than
the fact that this moment carries some
value for you don't get no better than
this it really doesn't
thank you but thank you Harry Belafonte
for never in my wildest wildest
imaginings what I think that you would
share a few bars of Dale with us and for
the wisdom that you brought to the class
and thank you students for joining in
this most inspiring conversation with
what who I believe to be one of the
world's greatest philanthropist this has
been philanthropy in action you know
Harry Belafonte shared with us that
moment in which the entire world was
singing his song day oh and he thought
how could I use that moment to make the
world a better place and he did and he
talks about how we actually find our
moral Center and how we make that
decision about whether we are invested
in making money or in the moment that he
said when he wakes up and he can speak
to Nelson Mandela and we are so
privileged here today that we could wake
up today to speak with Harry Belafonte
and there is no greater privilege that I
can imagine now what are you going to do
to change the world